yes I closed the book with the XO
otherwise known as the One Laptop Per
child project because I feel in some
ways that in the developed world we've
had our romp through generative
technologies at a time when we had the
innocence of not realizing just how
important they'd become we can do stuff
unselfconsciously code those flying
toasters because it was all fun it
wasn't some huge calm play worth
billions of dollars at the time we were
messing around and it's harder to keep
that sense of unselfconsciousness going
now that we know what the stakes are and
how vitally important the technologies
have become I think in the developing
world there's less at the moment
invested in it and as the next one to
two billion people get online what
technologies will they be given will it
be in a consumerist model here's a new
mobile phone and you can use this mobile
phone to check the weather and see crop
reports and stuff like that very useful
but sterile or will it be a technology
that lets people in those communities
the one nerd out of 2,000 that might be
hanging around and that learns to affect
the way the phone works will they have a
chance to have a vote and to hack around
and to have fun and I'm hoping the
answer is yes on the faith that when
they do it'll be put generally to
interesting and good uses rather than
two bad ones there are people i quote in
that chapter gene spafford at purdue who
says I can't believe this one laptop per
child program that's putting more or
less generative laptops in the hands of
kids it's like my god we have the plague
going on right now what we need is to
give rats to people because he's
figuring there's already enough spam in
trouble why would you give people the
tools to make more and I guess I
disagree with that but that's a that's a
risk it's a spin of the wheel to see how
it will be used it's also interesting to
see the ways in which the one laptop per
child is a combination
sterile and generative in order not to
have kids have them stolen from them
soon after they received them they
actually have a phone home feature if
the laptop doesn't check in a designated
school every so often it dies and that
makes it less worthy of stealing just
like a car with a LoJack that disables
the car and that requires some element
of control from the center
you